um
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
and executive producer of the
national actually sorry guys we don't
even have time for that because we have
uh things are happening right now i'm
going to explain to you guys what's
going on with today's stream it's quite
a stream here is presumably uh british
prime minister boris johnson showing up
um he is meeting at the white house with
president joe biden
we have there were some technical
elements that were moved around so the
super chat thing over there is like a
little bit misframed i'm going to fix it
once we get some super chats we're going
to get it all working properly and
everything let's see what's happening
here
oh there may not even actually be audio
here
um okay we'll just keep an eye out
on what's going on uh there is boris
johnson who just admitted to having six
kids i didn't know that that was even a
controversy but he did
um
i guess it was
controversial and he heads into the
white house
and so that is uh his arrival
and then we are standing by for an
actual event of the top of the bilateral
meeting between joe biden and boris
johnson so we're standing by for that
we'll keep it right here
and um
presumably that's all going to get going
very very soon scheduled for two minutes
from now
so really running on schedule which you
you quite frankly love to
see uh
let's see here um yeah we'll just
monitor both feeds i guess
and it's all going to be happening i
have so many things to go over with
everybody today
i'm going to be appearing in a little
bit on the dylan burns twitch channel
dylan will be interviewing me and i
figured i would stream it it would be a
good you know bit of content as the kids
these days say so that'll be at the top
of the next hour um we might review some
of dylan's work at the second uh
i mean the failed trump riot i guess we
would call it
um on saturday he was interviewing some
people so we're going to talk about that
i have a bunch of different
clips to play for you i also have
voicemails i have uh there's just a ton
of different things going on
let me see what else i had my list here
i guess that's the majority of it but
that's a lot of stuff that'll get us to
the dylan burns interview
um at the top of the hour so we're
standing by for all of that and standing
by for joe biden and boris johnson uh
boris johnson just now arriving at the
white house james montalbano says via
super chat sir sir a test super chat for
you yeah it takes a little while until
they let's see like my instinct is it
probably needs to be wider more like
that
let's see on the other shot that may
actually be working fine
see if we can just tweak a little bit
and then maybe move down
and then enlarge yeah we'll see as as
the super chats show up
thanks to kane 609 as well as chill sd
sheldon black
and jen here oh and margot cabot and
small fuzzy moss as well that's one two
three four five six people uh putting us
okay zero plus six
that's six that i've got
very much understand that one today's
coupon code is felony 21 in case anybody
is curious about that
oh i also have an unban request to
adjudicate let me maybe just do that
first just to get it out of the way
um when people get banned on twitch they
can request to be unbanned and i will
you know make a decision with my gavel
user very moist towelette
came in with the message
zionist scum
they were banned
and then they said as their unbanned
request was what i said untrue is david
not a zionist piece of [ __ ]
that is a
perma-ban obviously
so that one we get that doesn't even
really require
too much introspection
oh okay here are the super chats all
right good
so let's see i think we can probably go
a little bit bigger
um that's looking pretty good to me
and then the next one will show up down
below
that's pretty good right on this shot
and then let's see on this other shot i
look good actually i think we've got the
super chat stuff pretty much fixed
um ethan says woe upon you who deny him
for he will deny you in the world to
come all right and alexis says i hope
you're having a great day love from
philly thank you alexa very much
appreciate that also thank you to beth
graham and elevated disc golf
for the twitch subs um it looks like now
we've got a little welcome mat being
brought out by the marines
um or is that the map they stand on that
i think that's the map they must stand
on probably better for the knees
um
okay good
we're standing by all of that stuff all
right good so we've gotten the
ban adjudication out of the way that is
done
let's look at a couple of other things
as i mentioned apparently this is a
controversy
i didn't know about it but since boris
johnson is in town i figure i'll mention
it boris johnson
admits he has six children
boris johnson has finally admitted that
he has six children a question he has
previously dodged in numerous interviews
and press conferences the british prime
minister speaking to nbc's today show on
the sidelines of the un general assembly
was asked by an interviewer
if he had six children to which he
replied yes
the number of children sired by johnson
has been a talking point in british
politics for many years after an english
court discharged an injunction
banning news organizations from
reporting the existence of a daughter
as the result of an extramarital
affair
that's really weird right
oh hold on a second do we
oh no did i lose my audio
oh no guys i might have lost my various
uh
do we have it let's see here
i'm trying to play clips that narrate
what i'm saying
wait where is this audio coming from is
it here
uh yeah
you're trying to play stefceffahyde it's
not working
oh wait or is it working but it's me who
can't hear it is that what's going on is
it just me who can't hear it
oh i know exactly what's going on
yup yup yup
surfy
there it is
there it is okay good
all right so anyway i missed the
opportunity for that it was it was i who
could not hear it i apologize for that
i apologize for that thanks to samuel
plavidal who just signed up on my
website with the coupon code felony21
very much appreciate that
other super chats coming in more love
from philly they're closing the schools
because of all the coved
clusters many kids are getting pretty
seriously ill yeah i heard that and
that's absolutely horrifying
good day sir i don't believe your
vegetables survived through your
vacation no one was there to water them
the instagram post was a powerful cover
up no vegetables are doing fine
i'm curious if your opinion on the new
alcus alliance seems like france is
overreacting a bit love the show david
thanks
i have nothing to say about it quite yet
thoughts on the canadian election love
the show i am unsurprised by the results
brett says sir is messy better than
maradona uh different eras very
difficult to say
what is your guess for your end of the
year subscriber number um
let me think we're adding about
15 000 youtube subscribers a month so
october november december that would be
45 45
where are we right now
45 and 1.39
put us at about 1.43
you know
my goal is to be at 1.5 million by the
end of the year although i i'm aware
that that's very much a stretch goal i
understand that that we may or may not
make it to that but i would love to be
that's where i would love to be by the
end of the year i think it would be
really great
um okay so boris johnson sired six
children
uh here's a wacky video
um
i don't even really know what the the
context is
but i love that eventually police just
get sick of this woman and say that's it
you're under arrest check this out i
have to identify myself you do actually
i don't it's called common law you
should read up on it i do not
okay so we both know that i don't i am
this looks like one of the most
disgusting people i would ever come
across men of god this is my right as
much as it is oh this is old that's
interesting i only saw it posted on
september 20th yesterday this is my land
as much as it is yours i did not
sign up for this i am a christian woman
of god and you are not going to put your
disgusting rules on me that are false
and not true i will not have it
hold on a second are things getting
going oh no that must have been noise
coming from the background sorry about
that can that i will not have it i'm
sick of being bullied i'm sick of being
lied to and it's what does it mean to be
bullied not gonna happen anymore do you
understand
the cdc just released turn around oh my
gosh
i don't know why i just love that at a
certain point police are just like all
right that's it now you're coming with
us oh my gosh
yeah anyway so that's new to me i know
people are saying uh that that's old i
had not seen it before i like it quite a
bit
um
beef stews has subscribed via twitch so
has micro kimi and rich bird nation as
well as a danish joint and slingblade
triple nine putting us at 14 for the day
remember that the website coupon code
today is felony21 why
the code is so extreme
it should be a felony and i want to say
thanks to daniel lanois
for signing up on my website you are new
member number 15 today
the door just slightly slightly ajar and
out comes a gentleman at least i assume
he's a gentleman
we are standing by for joe biden and
boris johnson there's going to be what's
called a pool spray at the top of the
hour it's not what you think it is
that's for sure
uh let's see here other super chats 40
year old virgil says bojo is a bad
weirdo who doesn't know how many kids he
has yet loves starving the rest of the
kids in the uk
and skimming off dodgy deals for himself
that's aggressive
jimmy from philly says why do your
subscribers love me you should ask them
jimmy
thoughts about the reconciliation bill
tons of reconciliation content on the
podcast and bonus show today so i'm not
gonna you know go over that
james says sir
will you do a tdps segment on the
breitbart john nolte piece claiming the
left is using reverse psychology
manipulating trumpers to stay
unvaccinated yeah i might cover that it
is interesting it's very very
interesting
jimmy from philly says david are you gay
i am not
um
all right so we're caught up
there
i want to make sure i don't miss
whichever one of these feeds is going to
have the actual
biden boris johnson spray
if you're just joining us at the top of
the next hour 6 p.m eastern i'm going to
be interviewed by dylan burns
who is a
twitch streamer
and he was gracious enough to invite me
onto his channel so i will be
simulcasting that interview
um i don't actually know what we're
going to talk about but that'll be
that'll be eventually
so i'm glad to be
um
presenting that to everybody
i have a huge huge backlog
of voicemails
and i want to play
some of these voicemails for you some
will be from characters you know
some will be from characters that you
don't know a known entity of course is
this young lady
hi pepin um so i was researching about
libertarianism
and
um it looks like it could like swing
left or right
so i kind of like thought i was a
libertarian for a while until i started
like looking into it more deeply and
then i was like
it makes sense on the list
all right next voicemail
but america like creating a man that's
like this like extremely good marketing
tool makes the economy a lot of money
is like really confusing in a lot of
ways income right exactly i have what i
believe is a new caller
actually wait a second i also have eric
from mass who's a covet conspiracist man
it's it's like an abundance of riches
today let's see who we've got first
hey buddy it's eric from math again i i
hate to be the bearer of bad news but
guess what on the nih.gov website
number two treatment for glovin19
ivermectin
this guy has been warning me for six
months that i'm gonna end up in jail
because of the things i say about kovid
for months and months and months he's
been warning me that that is ultimately
going to be my fate he also left this
one
hey david it's sarah from mass um
this calls to really bad because i just
hate to tell you i've been trying to
tell you and now project veritas came
out and confirmed everything i've been
trying to tell you about the vaccines um
i wanted you to get on the right side of
this um
evidently you've never heard of the
journalistic uh phrase do you want to be
first or do you want to be right you
shouldn't let time go by you said the
vaccines were 100 and 90 80
um yeah anyway i never said anything was
100 about the vaccines and uh again
this guy's been warning me it's really
more like a year that i'm going to end
up in prison because of the things i've
said about uh kovid
so there is that then i think we go from
eric from mass i think this is probably
troy york
kyle kaminsky is a funky idiot he keeps
lying okay we'll call him i don't know
why you're calling me about that
uh the question david is why has it
taken so long
for the democrats and this
dribbling idiot president joe biden to
do something about the borders the only
reason he's doing anything and shipping
the haitians back to haiti where they
belong
is because he's being forced to do it
they got so egregious that
all right then it's eric from mass again
hey david it's eric from math oh man
what are you gonna do dude you just
walked into the
oldest trap in the book i told you you
were racist
and now it's a proven fact uh
did you see carmine's
yeah you're rooting on for mandates and
it's discriminatory okay i don't know
what eric is talking about but he's he's
really sure i'm gonna end up in prison
very soon very very soon um all right
let's go to some other folks
uh
oh so here's a new caller a regular
caller they left
it looks like 27 voicemails in a row
starting at 3 48 am okay let's take a
listen nuke i think this is a new caller
hey david
um i found
pretty much the entire problem with our
country and it's pretty freaking stupid
it comes down to
ironically about point zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero keep going and then
put a one at the end i don't know how
far but put a one at the end
and then
make a hundred okay then he called back
hey david sagan uh
you could
you can hear anything i don't really
care um obviously you have the right to
um certain things like this i would
rather not you air but i don't really
care that one he doesn't want aired then
he called back
i also have an interesting paper i wrote
back in the 90s about global warming
all right then he called back these are
all the full three minutes by the way
and then they're timing out and he's
calling right back
hey david how you doing i just wanted to
leave a little story about a little
experience in a store i had the other
day
i walked in and i don't remember what
triggered me but it was it was something
they were parroting fox and it was a
flat out lie
so i called it out
now my dad called me
from a colbit ward in florida after
going down because he thought he could
get a vaccine and being lied to okay
then that one timed out called right
back
but david this is what i'm literally
think of your brain as a computer okay
okay they're seeing a hundred and seeing
it as a higher number than anything
below it there is no that's logical and
100 is a higher number than anything
below it
all right david i wanted to call jesse
but uh somehow his line got disconnected
jesse who lee peterson i don't even know
what this is about
and i'm going to tell you this david and
we aliens know this and those christian
evangelists should pay for this
john lennon is dead because they
freaking hypnotized the guy and they
made him shoot him okay we're going to
move on now but that's a new caller so
that's something to look forward to
then we're going to
drunk chicago guy as you can see things
have really escalated uh on the
voicemail line
i'm actually getting paid the league
yeah my landlord's paying me the lead so
i kind of tripped
and i'm going to take care of nevada and
arizona
and
the bears won which is awesome
okay called back
tg dg from chicago respond
don't be yet
respond
don't react
your parents want to vote for ronda
sanchez okay then they called back
my
my blind cousin nikki taught me how to
say ew
like you know so it is
people want to code for this guy
okay then called back you know what the
girl who took to toby ill
yeah she's probably she is probably a
republican because of her husband
you know for the taxes and stuff
but she's like i think i'm a democrat
now i got a johnson and johnson all
right so anyway they called back a few
more times we're going to move on from
that
um next we're this is there's like a lot
here's another
this could be troy york or not i can't
tell it's an unknown number hey david
hey david uh why do you keep talking
about these
anti-vaccine radio hosts
that are dying cold how did you know
that they really died of cold
and this isn't just some medical
uh emergency
advertising care
it was a medical emergency it's called
covet your fair monitoring that's
the left-wing maniacs too
you have no proof that uh
they died of coping and why don't you
talk about the number of left-wing
regular hosts
who have died from taking the vaccine
well the number is zero of course and he
called right back yeah david and this is
herbert gilbert again
i want to say that i'm going to cancel
my membership to the channel all right
go ahead troy thank you i want to say
thanks to life is good 63
as well as iri man who just signed up
via twitch prime and are new members 16
and 17. also
please consider yourself personally
invited by me
by me
to sign up on my website joinpakman.com
today's coupon code is felony21 because
the discount is so big
it's hard to believe it's legal all
right let me do a couple of adjustments
here to the super chats
there we go let me get back to super
chats um
david has changed i've noticed dave has
become more pretentious and
condescending since hitting 1 million
followers
followers
see psychologist interview with trump
supporter
okay if we don't address money in
elections first how long will progress
in regulations taxes and education last
it seems inevitable to slide backward
yeah i've talked about as meta issues
uh money in politics how our elections
work
uh and climate change those are the meta
issues whatever issue you care about in
particular
the path forward will be dictated
by those three issues
you think uh this is nehemiah davis you
think the fed vacs mandates will hold if
challenged in court i i don't know i've
said i'm not sure
also do you think the mandates could be
an expanse of potus power if so not why
um
no i don't think so because uh we
you know government vaccine mandates go
all the way back at least to 1905.
and so if this has been an expansion
it's been the slowest expansion in
history it's also not really a mandate
you can test out
david do you think the damage from
hurricane item proved how much we need
to update infrastructure especially
coastal cities like new orleans of
course
without a doubt
without a doubt
dan says it's linois not lenoir but
you're welcome for the membership love
your show don't always agree but always
found you very honest i appreciate that
thank you
uh semi truck driver says thoughts on
the border patrol agents whipping folk
i'm against it i'm against them even
having whips who gave them the whips
why do they have whips it's bizarre it's
bizarre
um okay
sir i apologize powerly powerfully for
the state of our prime minister and what
you're about to see he's a national
embarrassment well we will see shortly
jimmy says why won't you debate the hard
bastard david i i don't know who that is
i don't really
do debates i i mean what the debate
would be about what i mean i don't know
pretentious pacman says david refuses
selfie with his fans whoa
that's pretty aggressive
i don't know how we'll possibly survive
that
um let me get to a couple of other super
chats here um voice mails rather
all right david uh i'm watching a video
on youtube
uh by salty cracker
and we're done moving on
mr pacman here are some uh policy
uh and uh procedural rebuttals please
for all of the vaccine all of the virus
procedural collaborators out there who
want to soft shoe themselves is either
anti-vaxx or anti-mask okay okay
first off i think that uh
policy wise
that
we should say that
is my show playing in the background i
think it is
from coronavirus 19
when the deceased was medically eligible
to be vaccinated
should we rule the suicide
and therefore excluded from life
insurance
that's interesting so if it really is
only them
and they're choosing to risk committing
suicide by covet 19. right then um there
should be no insurance policy payout for
life insurance policies
okay i could be convinced of that for
suicide
there i don't think there's such a thing
as an all-risk life insurance policy
if there is i'm sure that the premium is
extraordinarily high right that's an
interesting point i'm going to move on
but that is that is interesting same
caller different voicemail
mr packman um you know
you keep saying
i don't know what we're gonna do about
all this brainwashing i don't know what
we're gonna do about all these crazy
people who don't understand the truth or
the facts
well you know that's the lost cause
the group that we need to be speaking to
are the folks who continue to be
rational
the folks who continue to try to speak
the truth even if they are being misled
all right a very important point
um let's look at a couple other these
are a lot of the you know unknown people
who block their number so sometimes it's
troy york sometimes it's that guy
sometimes it's you know our female
friend
david peckman
i think that the far left
[Music]
they seek to
distract uh joe biden
uh produce this new delta
yeah okay joe biden produce the delta
variant there you go that's even a
little bit too too much
um
let's see what else i've got for folks
you guys want to hear from new hampshire
new hampshire is always interesting
because it could really go either way
hi it's joe from new hampshire i was uh
i was at an air show last weekend and
i'm sure you can imagine
uh the majority of who goes to air shows
um i don't count myself among those
members i just like airplanes but um
yeah a lot a lot of trumpets there a lot
of thin blue line shirts and all that
and i was i was kind of eavesdropping on
a couple of them just while i was
hanging out and uh some of the stuff
they were saying was just absolutely
like
not grounded in any reality
even that i've heard from republicans
and trumpists lately like
i
i feel like at this point the trumpets
like conspiracy theory generation
is completely automated and independent
of
anything a politician might say
yes and no i mean i i agree with the
idea that there are people for whom
their ideology is essentially just
contrarian conspiracy theories that's
true and it just so happens like for
cultural reasons or geographical reasons
or whatever that they lean
right politically but really the main
thing is conspiracism
um but at the same time
i i wouldn't say it's totally divorced
from politics let me put it that way
a few other super chats coming in uh ali
says david do you prefer chicken wings
or attendees i prefer attendees
certainly
mason says please do a collaboration
with brian tyler cohen it would be a
dream come true for me i would love to
stephanie asking david uh would you
travel to space or a particular planet
yes i would go to i would go to titan
specifically not really a planet it's a
moon but i would still go chris says
david sir my friend is convinced the
only way to drink coffee is black how do
i get through to anti-dairy folk you
know i don't really concern myself with
how other people want to drink their
coffee
maybe that's the libertarian streak that
i have but as long as i can drink my
coffee however i want i don't really
care how other people drink coffee
call me crazy guys
um
biden is president but david uploads
trump clips over biden clips three two
one is he worried about the drop in
views talk about biden's policies we
talk about biden's policies all the time
um
views are up
and
everything's fine syed ahmad says david
sir would it be possible to interview
people like diamond and silk in the same
way you interviewed mike pillow i would
love to have diamond and silk on the
show anytime
absolutely anytime
sam says what software are you using for
live feeds stream labs obs is the
software that i use
i want to say thanks to the freak as
well as jeff builds a base for signing
up via twitch prime numbers 18 and 19
today if you're watching via twitch feel
free to re-up that twitch subscription
always love that
and uh in all seriousness
sign up on the website that's that's the
place to go
join pacman.com today's coupon code is
felony21
these discount codes are felonious make
sure they don't get you
would i consider interviewing senator
john tester
yes absolutely
curious how he got elected as a democrat
in a red state like montana yeah i would
and montana had that um
democratic governor for a while brian
anybody remember his name what was that
guy's name brian
something
montana governor brian schweitzer
yeah um is he still governor
no he hasn't been governor for eight
years okay
oh boy we'll cut that out of this out of
the stream yeah no no concerns about
that if you're just joining us we are
standing by for two different things
number one
half an hour ago we were waiting for a
spray
a pool spray strange name but that's
what it is involving boris johnson the
british prime minister and president joe
biden
that's about a half hour delayed we're
expecting it any moment then at the top
of the hour i'm going to be interviewed
by dylan burns let's see what's
happening on his channel is he live
right now dylan burns has graciously
asked me for an interview
uh he is not currently live but he will
be interviewing me at the top of the
hour and i will i will remain live
during that period of time
so that everybody can see what's going
on alex says sir check out toontoon's
new egg roll video oh yeah uh it's been
a while since i've checked in on
toontoon
let's see what's going on
um
toontoon channel here it is
this is um
this is someone i know and we've
recommended their youtube channel before
they do mostly thai cooking
how to make egg rolls these are
beautifully filmed let's take a quick
look
up to 8 000 subscribers welcome back
someone is certainly hungry hello strong
dog video
today i'm making a childhood favorite
crispy egg rolls two ways wow one with a
classic pork filling and the other with
the potato curry whoa
it's so satisfying to eat
perfect for parties
let's get started
right
first let's make the pork filling
we'll need to soften up some glass
noodles with hot water
[Music]
snip them into manageable pieces whoa
all right well now this is great we're
not going to watch full full-on cooking
videos now um but make sure to check out
the toontoon channel now at eight
thousand ninety eight thousand ninety
uh where is the pacman live channel at
ten thousand six hundred beautiful
remember uh youtube.com
davidpakman.compacmanlive we also have
a second channel and a lot of stuff from
the streams appears on here remember
this moment this was actually pretty
funny voicemail about the entire jimmy
from philly dr k thing
hi david i was just watching your live
stream with uh dr k and and jimmy dore
and i haven't watched jimmy dore for a
while but oh my god does this guy think
jimmy from philly is actually jimmy dore
is it at all possible on this planet
that someone watched the two-hour
session
with dr k and jimmy from philly
and thought
that was jimmy dore
is is it even
is it even at all possible that that's
what someone came away believing that
that's the jimmy door that people are
talking about anyway so that's the
pacman live channel which you can find
at
davidpakman.com
pacmanlive or
youtube.com
pacmanlive okay so all of those things
happening
simultaneously
and very very strongly
do you like the band spoon i don't know
much about the band spoon quite frankly
um what about kristen cinema
what about her papi you'd have to be a
little bit more specific about that i'm
not uh
not a hundred percent sure what you mean
there
thanks to kay gouldi as well as it's too
legit
and the freak for signing up via twitch
you were numbers 20 21 and 22 very much
appreciate that
um
[Music]
okay let's do a couple other voicemails
let's see here's a random one
hi david
um
my name is tom and i am calling in today
from uh indiana uh specifically
valparaiso and i actually wanted to get
your opinion
and perception um on the story that
happened in my hometown so
um
vaporez is actually in northern indiana
up by chicago
and every year in september we have a
popcorn parade that takes place downtown
to honor orville redenbacher um
since he's from our own town and uh you
know pretty notable figure um
but what was different about this parade
this year is that it happened to be on
saturday september 11th so there was a
little bit of kind of a 911 i wouldn't
necessarily say okay we're gonna move on
but that is very very interesting
hi david uh i was going to ask you about
the audit going on in arizona
the maricopa county audit that has been
going on since april of 2021
i need eleven thousand bucks give me a
break they're finding every excuse under
the sun
to just keep this going and going
uh they're not willing to be transparent
and guys it's not even a real audit like
i hesitate to even seriously entertain
it
um
the eggman called in about the bonus
show
hey dave can i be the first probably not
to tell you that your bonus show shift
to bed again on the
production value but um still fun shalom
brother hello meg man i appreciate the
call uh yeah we had a couple technical
problems on a bonus show last week
um
a couple others hey dave i'm a big fan
of the show i have a question um
regarding an important issue
looks like we're getting some electrical
hum there they called right back
hey david i heard you did segment where
you said um about 20 or 30 20 or 30 uh
email addresses go directly to the trash
when they email you at info
davidpakman.com yeah i was curious um
how do you know those people are sending
you terroristic threats in the emails if
you're just sending them straight to the
trash that's a beautiful question
actually so that's it's absolutely true
right now
we have about actually no so we have
about 20 or 30 email addresses when when
people email those peop there's people
that will email a dozen times a day
every day for years
and when they are not
threatening people
we automatically filter those into an
audience emails folder so they're there
and we can review them at any time and
every once in a while i'll go through
and see if there's anything pertinent or
anything that needs a response but like
for example just looking at the last 12
hours
there are one
two
three
four five
six
seven
eight different people who have emailed
multiple times over the last 12 hours we
filter them into a folder
there's about three people whose emails
are automatically filtered into the
trash and we know that those folks that
it's like they're just sending us
articles articles articles you know does
2 20 30 40 emails a day just with
articles no comment nothing and we know
that they're not dangerous people
otherwise we would of course keep it so
you know to forward to the fbi or
whatnot but no the ones filtered into
the trash are just people where we write
back and we explain you know
this is not a valid way to communicate
with me you know you've got to call in
if you want to talk to me but this is
not this is just clogging our inbox
sending us 50 articles a day doesn't
make sense
um those are the only ones we would
filter into the trash almost all of the
filtered ones are filtered directly into
a folder and reviewed every couple weeks
just to see what's uh just to see what's
there um okay let me get back to a
couple of other voicemails i had here
uh
where was it here we go oh yeah
i wanna know why you samsung
have the same title about republicans
oh no sam cedar
losing in the states that sam
transformed all right well that's uh
troy york just calling in calling colin
calling it's just non-stop
um
all right i think that's probably good
as far as
voicemails are concerned
i'm just curious about one other one
here
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
whoa
um and they they continue to call that's
weird
oh this is j i'm so stupid this is jimmy
from philly's number hey you guys want
to hear something absolutely hilarious
about jimmy from philly
this is so funny
i don't know how many of you remember
but a couple streams ago i played five
voicemails in a row from jimmy from
philly now of the five
in one of them jimmy actually was
speaking the others were like sirens it
might have been tv shows whatever we
have caller id
all the numbers were all all five calls
were from the same number it's jimmy's
number and they all came in within 15
minutes of each of each other
jimmy sent me an email the day after
saying david
one of those calls was me the others
were people spoofing my number
does anyone think that first of all
someone knows jimmy's number and is
calling me spoofing it but on top of
everything
they call within five minutes of jimmy
actually calling me and they call with
the exact same static on the line except
instead of being static plus jimmy's
voice it's static plus police sirens
like
the odds of this are you know narrower
than winning the mega millions it just
it's completely impossible
uh okay
very good so that's done we're standing
by for joe biden
scheduled for almost 40 minutes ago to
do a pool spray
with the boris johnson
and then in about 35 minutes i'm going
to be interviewed by dylan burns
dylan burns has a twitch channel
and i'm going to be interviewed by dylan
let's see if he's gone live now
um nope not yet but dylan's gonna be
interviewing me at the top of the hour
and i think that that's gonna be very
very interesting okay so we're gonna
keep an eye on that let's get to a
couple of other things
we did this arrest
um oh this is really funny
this is a real promo that newsmax is
running of trump saying newsmax is
pretty good the former president of the
united states
and you know i wouldn't say fox has been
exactly perfect fox has been a big
difference at fox between
now and what it was four years ago as
you know
but we have others that come along and
they're doing well and uh
newsmax has been really good and you
know others are coming along and people
what a powerful endorsement people are
seeing that they're watching these
conservative networks
president trump is right that's why
millions of americans are tuning into
newsmax for the real news they can trust
exactly exactly so that's a new ad
over there also this is really funny um
you guys remember the failed trump riot
on saturday right we covered it
um
dinesh d'azuza
suggested that the entire thing was a
false flag cooked up by the fbi and
actually got into an argument with the
organizer on twitter and what's funny is
dinesh follows the actual organizer like
dinesh knows the the real organizer
and the organizer wrote back like dude
you follow me what are you what are you
talking about like it wasn't a i
organized it you know me you followed me
what the hell are you talking about so
dinesh posts
the fbi tried to cook up an insurrection
this weekend so they could make arrests
and commend themselves for their amazing
work that would at the very least call
for a nice increase in their budget
unfortunately hardly anyone showed up so
then matt brainard the actual organizer
says
you literally follow me here on twitter
beginning to understand now why one of
the wright's loom quote luminaries is so
smart he caught a felony conviction for
making fraudulent campaign contributions
fraud
uh dinesh d'souza
real genius yeah i love it when they
argue with each other
it's just it's just absolutely fantastic
um and then one other element i have for
you guys is this is pretty funny this is
josh i don't know i i never remember if
it's mandel oh hold on no we're good i
never remember if it's mandel or mandel
this congressman this republican
congressman
he tweeted a couple days ago you can't
spell pandemic
without dem
is this a coincidence whoa
that's pretty clever right guys
and this is the same josh mandel who did
this bizarre ad
in a cornfield where you can barely even
hear them remember this i played this
for you guys a few days ago hey guys
it's thursday night september 9th
i'm driving through western ohio we're
driving through a corn field right near
a town called logansville ohio
my uh blood is boiling
enraged at what i've seen
from the white house today right
trampling on our freedom
tramping on our liberty tramping on what
i took it's anyone's guess what this was
about because this is exactly what they
always say democrats are trembling on
our freedom i think it's about
vaccination oath to defend when i joined
the marine corps
joe biden i'm not even going to call him
president biden he's not joe biden is
creating a constitutional crisis and as
i was driving through this corn field
yeah
i literally came across this sign this
trump sign he is my president wow
and i am hoping and praying that the
supreme court justices that he appointed
to the u.s supreme court will do the
right thing
and stand up for the constitution stand
up for our freedom stand up for our
liberty
and if they don't
i call on my fellow americans do not
comply do not comply with the tyranny
and when the gestapo show up at your
front gestapo what's up with all these
guys like alex jones
and josh mandel
saying gestapo like what what what is up
with that anybody know what's going on
with that
gestapo
the frog
um okay all right so we've got that and
then um
i i did have a uh
actually i've got a couple different fox
news clips
this is a guy i used to think this guy's
name was titus i guess his name is
tyrus
he made whoa he had a um
an opinion that i thought was
interesting
disaster after disaster and biden
peddles faster
this is a comedy show yes says old joe
toodles on his schwinn
americans take it on the chin
the president spent the weekend
vacationing in delaware apparently the
only place where he won't get lost
[Laughter]
he enjoyed a beachside bike ride
ignoring reporters as he whizzed on by
he's just like lance armstrong except
there's no drugs that'll enhance his
performance
this is like maybe the worst show on fox
which which says a lot
nice
now aside from the buzzards circling
above him
biden's not the only one who enjoys the
beach
taliban terrorists snapped these vacay
picks
trading in tanks for pedal boats at a
lake that's popular with horny spring
breakers
and we do mean horny since the bikini
babes were all sheep
they remember they remembered to pack
sunscreen speedos and assault rifles
which you know was the original name for
life liberty and levine
one hopes with their new love of water
can soap be far behind for the taliban
but back to biden
according to bob woodward's new book
peril top aides have tried to shield him
from long interviews and unscripted
events and by long they mean anything
that cuts into his pudding time
they call it it's so weird because you
know trump played golf 20 of the days
that he was president and uh
you know
didn't work at all and would start
working at noon all the effect a
cocooning of the president which
protects biden from tough questions and
children from being sniffed by joe biden
by the way cocoon was an 80s movie about
old folks starring wilfred brimley who
was 26 younger than joe biden is now
i get a laugh 26 youngers well the
growing border crisis in del rio only
worsens and according to the polls our
country we're trying to get to tyrus's
commentary which is just crazy let's see
if we can get to it okay here we go
do everything i say
all right
papyrus is brian's advantage that he has
so many crises that we cannot focus on
just one crisis is crisis seize a word
is that a word i i'm actually i if it is
i want to know that
crises
it's not a word okay
yeah i was i always thought it was
crises one
no everyone's focusing on all of them at
the same time
that's why he's riding a bike
it looked like a late night tv like
murder she wrote like he's why does this
guy have a wrestling belt on the show
showing himself riding bikes and typing
on a typewriter and
gardening and doing all the things
around the house except the entire
world's exploding around him
another thing i find interesting is uh
pasaki every time she talks
um she always talks about his vast
experience in these situations he's been
doing this for over 50 years
so what has he got to say yes he should
have some really good stories like you
know in 1985 this happened and we
handled it this way or in 1997 this
happened or in 2000 or in 1814 when i
got my first pair of shoes
after slaying the dinosaurs but we're
not hearing anything
that is such a great point
new years of experience
sometimes you do things for 50 years and
you just get tired of it
but it's also the pageantry that they
did 50 years ago who's that guy got it
on tape now not on tv it's actually on
your phone never mind it's not a tape
that was like 30 years ago i would be
okay if you said google me
like google me in 85 that's the answer
like give us something but but whenever
you have some old guy at work who's what
on earth is this show i mean it's it's
oh here we go
today and it's great to be with you in
the in the white house
and this is a very important trip for us
in the in the uk
uh and we've seen some some great
progress just in the last
uh period and uh
it's great that the the ban has been
lifted on british beef and the the
people of the united states of america
can eat british beef and we're gonna be
working on land too and the land we're
working on we're working on the land but
what you did uh with the the travel so
that people can travel to
the us uh with two jabs is also
fantastic
uh and and very welcome we'll be working
on that for a long time but i think the
most important thing today has been uh
your speech joe to uh to anger
where you've made a commitment on uh
supporting the the world to adapt to
climate change doubling the american uh
commitment that's uh very important for
us we've made a 11.6 billion pound uh
commitment i made when i first became a
prime minister but it's it's fantastic
to see uh the united states really
stepping up and and
showing uh a lead a real real lead and
uh then of course uh there's uh
the progress that we're making in the uh
the defense technology uh partnership uh
that uh that you've led and uh with our
australian friends
that i think has great potential to
benefit uh the whole of the world and
the security
of of the whole of the world so
uh joe thank you for uh for having us
and
um i think you know we're boosting our
our shared agenda we want to build back
uh the world
together with you
and i think we want to renew uh and
strengthen our transatlantic bond and it
feels to me like it's it's going very
very well but i think would it be okay
if we just have a couple of
questions just uh just just a couple of
questions but for the i think we're
going to be ruthless i'm going to be
ruthless i'm going to go to
i'm going to go to harry cole uh from
the sun
uh he he
asked him the question
two things one uh that latter case is
being worked on i was under the
impression but i don't know this i want
to be clear
i was under the impression there had
been
a civil settlement reached but i don't
know that that's correct and uh and
based on what i've been told
it was it was not an intentional act it
was someone who is new to
driving on the wrong side of the road
oh we've covered that story and uh but
we're following i'll follow up on that i
i express my sympathies when it occurred
but i don't know the status of that case
right now
the other question was
approximately free trade
it's a little brexit free trial well
we're going to talk about trade a little
bit today
and uh we're gonna have to work that
through let me just say on that harry i
mean don't forget folks so we've we've
settled the the uh the the boeing airbus
thing which was a massive problem uh
between us so we're making a lot of
progress to say nothing of the beef and
the whiskey which i already i already
mentioned and uh just can i just say
smile when you said the whiskey
he's a great egg ambassador but on on on
the harry dunn
case which is a very very very sad case
and everybody's sympathies are with
the family of of harry dunn uh i know
that the president has been personally
trying to uh to move things along and i
i'm grateful for for that i'm gonna take
uh we're gonna take one more question
i'm going to go to
thank you
president trump said that uk was in
front of the queue when it came to a
trade deal you seem to have a different
approach is that because of your
heritage
your concern about
the irish protocol is that what's
holding it back when it comes to doing
this deal with the uk
there are two separate issues
on the deal with the uk that's
continued to be discussed
but on the protocols i feel very
strongly about those
we spent enormous amount of time and
effort in the united states it was a
major bipartisan effort made
and
i
i would not at all like to see
nor i might add would many of my
republican colleagues like to see
a change in the uh irish accords
and the end result having a closed
border again
and
that is absolutely right
and uh
i
on that point joe you know we are we are
completely at work boris johnson
interrupt there nobody wants to see
anything that uh
interrupts or uh unbalances the the
belfast good friday uh accords that's
the
belfast good friday agreement
that's that's the uh
[Music]
hope the microphone got it
i no
[Music]
british reporters good questions
oh salty
why do british reporters get questions
and we don't get any
wow
all right it seems that's the end of the
pool spray and it was
quite a spray i must say myself
um
okay it seems to have it seems to have
ended very very good
um
clipless no name okay good so let's see
um before we move on there was one other
uh
event
that i wanted to cover it relates to the
where is this
let me see if i can get this here
whoa
um hold on a second
this is not going well
let's see if we can get this all fixed
up
it relates to the audit ah there we go
okay
um
let's see if i can find it
the arizona audit which so many people
have been asking me about let me find it
here
uh
no it's not newsmax
i have to spice things up a bit oh my
god what is happening here
arizona let's see if i can just find it
this way
oh my god it's not happening all right i
guess it's not going on
uh okay oh people are curious what's
being advertised on newsmax yeah let me
pull it up while we transition to the
next phase here
upcom oh maybe it's under upcoming live
streams this is a very strange ad on
newsmax oh wait this is not newsmax this
is one two three go
where did newsmax go
ah here it is that's not being
advertised oh it's cawthorne let's
listen very milk toast mayorkas ripped
into border patrol agents for using what
he called whips on horseback to prevent
illegal aliens from crossing into
america in violation of our laws the
whips report was quickly debunked turns
out
people who know horses call those
leather straps they call them range you
know they help the writer tell the horse
where to go you can forgive mr michael
you got to be kidding me
but but this latest surge shows that
biden is in violation of a supreme court
order guys they weren't whipping them
with whips they were whipping them with
reins policy now those illegal aliens
should be on their way to mexico to
await their their asylum hearings
what will your office do to hold mr
biden and his lawless administration
nothing he does nothing current
violation of the supreme court ruling
well you can bet when we take the house
back in 2022 that we will be holding
them accountable for this open border
policy you see everything that's going
on the actual detrimental harm that this
is causing in my own hometown it's
detrimental harm as opposed to nice harm
old girl while he was drunk driving now
he just ran her over while she was
riding her tricycle and drove off
leaving her dead fortunately we have an
incredible sheriff in harrison county
who quickly hunted down the suspect and
it turns out this person had been de
deported already before and now because
of these open border policies he was
back and we have one less beautiful
young american girl living because of
the open border policies when this mild
toast mayorkas wants to tell us that we
actually are that he is horrified by
seeing these border patrol agents and
the texas rangers actually using what he
calls whips and i agree there's no
surprise that he doesn't actually know
what uh what rains look like because
there's no chance he's ever been
anywhere near a farm i don't see violent
aggression from these agents what i see
is desperation i see people who are
having to fight to try and secure our
southern border oh they support the
troops again i know you guys might have
been confused after the january 6th
stuff like i thought wait what happened
to support
now they support law enforcement okay
that's what's going on now i want to say
thanks to decimator 12
sweet thang
uh as well as badness for signing up via
twitch prime putting us at 25 if you're
just joining us we watched a very very
brief sort of like press
thing i i hesitate to call it a press
conference only two questions were taken
but with joe biden and boris johnson
and then in 15 minutes i'm going to be
appearing on the dylan burns twitch
stream he's going to be interviewing me
and i'll just stream live while it goes
on because why not why not let's see if
dylan is live dylan is live let's see
what's going on here with dylan's
channel who hides evidence
criminals hide evidence i had no idea
okay so we're going to keep an eye on
that because that's all going to be
coming up very very soon uh and we'll
get discord all set up for it
momentarily remember that today's coupon
code is felony 21. i would truly love it
if you signed up on my website
joinedpakman.com
you can get a coupon code so massive
that it must be a felony somewhere that
code is felony 21 felony 21
and you can uh i will thank everybody
who signs up using that let me get to
the one other
um tucker there was a tucker clip i
would what i actually wanted to play was
a tucker clip from last night not the
tyrus clip let's take a look at the
tucker clip been saying for months that
our southern border is out of control
that is completely open just in case you
think we've been over that's interesting
he's been saying it for months
but not years
hmm
i wonder about that we're stating that
here's this more than 13 000 haitians
have now crossed into del rio texas
jerome bill malugion has been on this
story like nobody else he was there on
saturday here's part of what he saw
you're looking at right now is that is
the u.s side of the rio grande that is a
mass of several hundred
illegal immigrants who have just crossed
the rio grande and look at this several
hundred more streaming across as we
speak we're on a boat in the rio grande
this is the mexican side of the river
right now
you can see it's a never-ending stream
hundreds of people crossing the rio
grande
basically every hour and they're heading
over to the international bridge which
you can see in the background
look at that mass of people
this is why the situation under the
bridge continues to deteriorate
this is insane the federal government
has to wake up
so a lot of questions here where do
these haitians come from how they get
here how they afford it they
they come from haiti right
right
but most pressing of all for americans
is where are these haitians going
u.s border patrol chief raul ortiz just
told malujian that of the 12 000
migrants under the bridge in del rio
only adult men will be deported here
right
the rest will be processed and released
into what you thought was your country
but turns out isn't
today fox news's peter ducey asked the
white house what our border czar thinks
about all of this
where's the vice president on any of
this isn't she supposed to be addressing
the root causes of migration absolutely
and she has been addressing the root
causes of migration by working with
countries in the region to ensure they
have the assistance they need to reduce
the number of people who are coming and
trying to make those journeys across the
border we've actually seen some
reductions in some of those numbers that
doesn't change the fact that this is a
very challenging situation in del rio
we're working to implement our policies
and we're working to
ensure we are also addressing root
causes
so why does our guy have to wear the
obedience mask and that woman doesn't
so many questions
someone who can answer a lot of those
questions as laura logan host of the
laura logan has no agenda wow this is
like everything combined
uh
we know why
jensaki is not wearing a mask and
everybody else is you know it doesn't
take that much much more than common
sense to understand that
um lara logan has now become
sort of a darling of the right after she
like called out uh
was it abc cbs that she called out this
is really hitting like every single one
of the highlights on fox nation which is
excellent she joins this site laura
thanks so much oh she has a show on fox
nation now that's wild for coming on so
how do these people get here where are
they going
do you know
well you know what's interesting about
these people tucker is that based on
what they're telling border patrol
agents when they're interviewed many of
them in fact if not most of them have
come from chile and brazil and countries
like that they're not actually coming
from haiti because they've been living
in latin american countries ever since
the earthquake so that's years now and
what they chile they are saying is that
the border is wide open everybody knows
it's wide open the message is loud and
clear they've seen people crossing there
for months the byte administration
doesn't do anything and this is their
chance so they said their lives are
pretty good i've seen many of them in
the it doesn't really pass the sniff
test that people came from chile
and mexico
actually this is the super chat here
this is the point from jessica it's
pretty bizarre that so many immigrants
just happen to travel the long way
through mexico
and arrive at the exact same time it is
a little bit strange to be telling the
story and saying these are people who
have been in chile the airports here as
they're cycled through and distributed
all over this country and they're well
dressed and you know very lovely people
from what i can tell you know
well-behaved great families but what
they don't look like is desperate they
don't look like for example christians
fleeing persecution from nigeria who are
actually in the midst of a genocide who
cannot even get asylum in this country
but it was the asylum roles are actually
written for them and what you're seeing
happen here is you know those thousands
of people in the bridge tucker you know
what the agents tell me they've got like
24 porter johns for those people several
hundred of them like around 300 escaped
on sunday morning they just ran away the
conditions are miserable they don't have
enough food they don't have any real
facilities or security it is an absolute
unmitigated disaster and what is it that
is so weird about these segments is it
the hypocrisy
relative to when donald trump was in
office
is it the sort of like
mischaracterization
of what
migrants are even
doing or trying to do
um is it just the expression on tucker's
face like is it all of these things i'm
not even i'm not even really sure like
what is it that makes this so vile what
you're seeing happen here is all those
people in the administration that came
from the open society foundation that
we're not allowed to talk about because
that'll be the end of us right is there
argument that these people shouldn't be
here at all or that they should be
treated better by
the biden border patrol like what does
anybody know what is the argument
actually is it both
they'll come for all of us well you know
what those people those advisors they
don't want a border what does open
society mean it means no borders which
means no america right no countries
that's why didn't she used to have an
australian accent does it that that's
another element to this what happened to
lara logan's australian accent
do i am i misremembering that
patriotism and the flag and all of those
things there's like a slight hint of it
i guess are so evil today right they're
automatically white supremacy and
nationalism never mind that you can be
you know an african company a country
and be proud of your your flag and your
borders or you can come from kosovo or
wherever so what you're seeing is part
of america is she south african or
australian i guess i don't remember
bigger political picture it's not just
about the border and it's the same
strategy as afghanistan ignore ignore
ignore pretend it's not there and not
happening and the biggest thing here
tucker is that people keep using words
like south africa so they failed to act
no they chose not to act they chose not
to act because they have the outcome
that they want
that is such a good point and bless you
for making it laura look
that's his regular line now right
that is such a good point and thank you
for making it what a bizarre segment
quite frankly
um okay we are soon going to be
partaking in an interview on the dylan
burns twitch channel
we've been monitoring that channel to
see what's going on
[Music]
okay so we're monitoring that um and
then i did want to just quickly look at
this kayleigh magnet administration
works to deport thousands of mostly uh
kaylee mcinanny i guess said that
it's bad that the biden administration
is lying asian migrants from an
encampment in del rio texas more than 20
000 haitians are now reportedly gathered
in colombia and may soon be headed to
the u.s nbc is reporting dhs is
monitoring this group as well as groups
of about fifteen hundred migrants in
panama and three thousand in peru
borders are vice president kamala harris
is facing criticism even on msnbc for
not doing more to address the search
meanwhile the white house is being
pressed on why foreign nationals are
required to be vaccinated but migrants
are not here's our peter ducey asking
press secretary jen saki about that
yesterday
if somebody walks
into the country right across the river
does somebody ask them to see
their vaccination card
well let me explain to you again peter
how our process works as individuals as
individuals come across the border
and
they are both assessed for whether they
have
any symptoms if they have symptoms they
are the intention is for them to be
quarantined that is our process they're
not intending to stay here for a lengthy
period of time
harris this is against the backdrop
however of thousands of them being
released into our states seemingly
permanently with really high coverage
does she is she making that up now they
care about covid like if she goes along
she's reading that they don't intend to
stay here long would you think they came
all these thousands of miles so they
could tiptoe in for 15 minutes
like what there's just such a level of
delusion in here right yeah and it's so
disappointing because it didn't have to
be this way and now you have all these
people living in probably arguably worse
quality conditions from where they're
coming from and they just got hit by an
earthquake and their president was
murdered like i mean haiti is no picnic
but now they they come here and this is
not
the land of the free that they're
hearing about by the way
senator marsha blackburn was uh was in
focus with me yesterday
and and said
that social media is playing a huge role
in this particularly facebook she's
taping taking an aim at them from the
hill they're getting ready to have some
hearings and do some things on this that
messages are being spread
and reaching
people and citizens in haiti and saying
come so it doesn't matter that secretary
of dhs mayorkas and the and the vice
president kamala harris are saying oh
you know don't come no with that how is
this even real coverage it's crazy here
is the loud megaphone that's broadcast
with our president of the united states
saying oh but you can come and he's been
saying that since he flipped the switch
on day one from donald trump's
presidential policies to his own just as
if he was answering a campaign pro
promise to some progressives because he
probably was
i mean where do we go from here and now
the midnight images
that the things that that normally are
happening in dark are happening in the
daytime yeah that's setting up a folk
great question in in twitch chat is this
a news show or is this an opinion show
i i i'm not sure i'm not sure what it's
what it's pretending to be deporting
them that is a horrible look
he doesn't i mean i agree with my last
guest last hour jason meister who worked
for the trump campaign he doesn't have a
base now
nobody's going to trust him
right and the green light that is sort
of being amplified on social media is
certainly it's only surging now because
many of those migrants have been in
third countries for the last year or
plus because we no longer have the
remaining mexico policy because we no
longer enforce our border then then the
green light being spread on social media
is being extra heard and that's why the
surge is occurring wow exactly and
kaylee we have um a sound bite from our
president haley it's your turn to lie
now please we'll play for you get your
reaction on the other side and whether
this what is happening on the hill is
senator hawley is grilling my orcas who
is testifying about his plan holly said
in private you told me you had a plan
when will this plan stop working to
which my work is replied it is working
to have the audacity to say something
like that it's an outright lie we've
heard lie after lie just yesterday my
orcas said she's saying others are lying
well the border's not open oh wait but
migrant crossings are at a 21-year high
there's no crisis he says but there were
over the weekend 14 000 that was the
high number of folks under the bridge
sitting in human excrement that's half
the population of del rio i think that's
defined as a crisis and then the most
appalling lie from gensake saying they
don't intend to stay right they traveled
1 900 miles to sit in human excrement
and build tense makeshift structures out
of trash bags that's what they did that
makes no sense she looks completely
different than when she was working for
trump isn't it strange we all see these
lies that's right and leo so we talk
about the actual covet spread this from
an administration that seems at least in
in words only to prioritize covet over
everything but the reality is that over
30 percent of these migrants are
refusing the vaccination what are these
other people that the rate of
transmission is above eight percent
reminder public schools were shut at
three percent and the the positivity
rate as they're being disseminated
throughout states i mean it's upwards of
15 000 for example in mcallen texas
these numbers are really horrifying but
it seems as if the administration only
looks at it from a humane condition if
they're republicans
oh let me be very clear emily it's only
if you're an american citizen there is a
inconsistent double standard the people
at the southern border who are entering
this country there is no covet
restrictions there is no covet
requirement there is no vaccine
requirement this is what drives the
american public crazy you're hearing a
mixed message a double standard the
reason why what you see down there which
is a third world country nice all right
i think i've basically had enough at
this point in time um we're gonna get
going on the um dylan burns show
momentarily okay we're about to make the
connection
and i'm gonna be interviewed by dylan
burns so we're standing by for that let
me make sure i've got everything going
ready here i wanna say thank you to
bubby cam as well as darth bane and
fandastis
as well as keolin lorde
all of whom just signed up via twitch
super chat uh twitch prime rather not
super chat numbers 26 27 28 and 29 also
big thank you to aniket banerjee
who just got a membership at
joinedpakman.com
with the coupon code
felony21 that's today's coupon code you
see it above my head felony 21
and it is
really a perfect coupon code i don't
know how else to say it but it's very
very good
um top of the hour i will be interviewed
by dylan burns
oh let me look at some super chats until
that time comes
uh sir what do you know about the
russian report exposing uk and u.s
election interference by russia
and their troll farms sir sure
being suppressed by boris i've not read
a lot about it yet admittedly i have a
couple articles um
set to set to be read
eric says hello david what's your
thought on celak the latin american
caribbean block they're trying to follow
the steps of the eu i understand the
motivation for it
i wonder
to what degree
latin america and the caribbean
have similar enough priorities
such that that might make sense i don't
know i'm asking the question i'm not i'm
not sure i guess is the point that i'm
trying to make but i'm interested in it
very much
david please collaborate with matt
dillahunty
david please interview kirsten cinema
all right all good suggestions i
appreciate that
um
let's see we must be pretty close to
when we're going to be starting here
with uh with dylan oh wow he has these
long intro videos huh
[Music]
don't you think you should take it they
said no no the subpoena required them to
take all electronics they said no no no
i feel sorry for that
okay um all right so we're keeping an
eye on that
um and very very soon i think we're
supposed to be starting this soon you
know the other thing i did by the way by
popular demand
typically when i'm streaming and and i'm
being interviewed by someone else my
audio on that other show is disastrous
why because it's audio coming from my
webcam which is way over there so what i
did today is i plugged in an additional
audio element this is a this is a blue
yeti
i've plugged it in and i'm putting it
right here
so that the audience on the other
channel will hear me through this
microphone and hopefully that'll be
better
um
let's see i i hope it's close enough is
the only thing let me get it as close as
i possibly can
um
okay good so that i think will maybe
make me sound better on on dylan's
channel let's listen a little bit to
sean spicer the remains of the service
members that came back we've got
congressman uh roger williams
congressman tom mcclintock talking the
border and then we'll break down biden's
speech at the u.n with senator steve
daines
god bless spicer and company i just
realized the guy on the left is chris
salcedo i've been on the radio with that
guy i've debated that guy on the radio
rally this weekend in georgia our
coverage begins at 6 00 p.m eastern on
saturday all right folks salcedo show
returns tomorrow five o'clock see you
then
wow uh okay dylan's about ready to call
um we'll be covering that rally in
principle i'll be covering it in
practice we'll see okay so we're gonna
we're gonna look at that at some point
in time
um
let me get set up here
so that we can get things going with
dylan i'm just going to go full screen
until we're all set up
let me see here and then we will do
this
and
where is discord here we go
um
all right i'm about to be interviewed
folks by dylan burns that's on the
agenda here
when dylan calls i'm going to get his
video set up
and then hopefully we'll all be able to
see him
and it's all going to be great i don't
know what we're going to be speaking
about
but
it's going to be uh it's going to be
it's going to be pretty good i think
much to discuss for sure
things upcoming um trump rally saturday
we've got um
it's really the only other thing
scheduled right now
uh
yeah i guess that's really the only
thing scheduled
what's your take on why fox was so
adamant on covering the gabby petito
story what's their angle
i just think those those salacious type
stories
um are perfect for fox that i don't
think there's anything particularly
special it's like it's just right up
their alley the same reason they cover
car chases and have covered car chases
for a really long time sometimes they'll
stick with them they just get ratings i
think it's really that simple
i think that's basically it
all right let's see here let's see if we
can get going um
let's see can you hear me dylan we can
hear you can you see me it's the first
question i can uh i can see you on your
stream but i can't see you in discord
okay
let me turn on camera
can you see me now
now i can see you mr pacman yes okay
wonderful let me change my audio to my
yeti is my audio better now
oh now i've lost you
um oh i changed my speakers to yeti i'm
sorry hold on let me turn
my
hold on that's output device
input device where do i set are you
hearing me through through my yeti
uh i can hear you fine you're absolutely
perfect i i don't know which one it is
uh from though let me mute it just let's
see if it goes away okay hold on
okay can you still hear me no
beautiful so we've got the yeti turned
on i love it
now let's see if i can get i think i can
now get your video up for my audience
uh
there we go okay i think we're in good
shape dylan
wonderful you have to deal with me i'm a
little unshaven at the moment the mask
mandate has uh made me uh compliant with
uh with with the less standard of
hygiene for shaving well you know what
happens to all of us it happens to all
of us
100
so how have you been i've been well i i
appreciate you having me on your show
you it came highly recommended that i
appear with you and i know i know we've
been trying to set it up for a while
yeah i was i was excited to i was really
excited to talk to you uh i didn't
actually think it was gonna happen when
uh when one of the people who work with
me actually suggested the idea so i'm
happy that it actually actually did
happen and after an exciting weekend too
at the capitol
yeah we covered when when i was
streaming saturday we picked up a little
bit of your interviews with some of the
people there
yeah it was it was some it was some very
interesting interviews
what really struck me was how readily uh
they all gave up information about
themselves not only would they state
their like full name but they would many
of them even stated yeah i was at the
capitol i tried to storm it no i haven't
the authorities have not contacted me
it's like why are you why are you saying
this in front of a camera this is a
terrible idea yeah it that was weird and
then the other thing also was
they um you know the the organizer i
think was like advising people don't
really do interviews don't talk to
people because you you know basically it
was clear that matt brainard thought
if people are interviewed they're gonna
look stupid and so he was advising
people not to and and they did i mean he
was exactly right
yeah i mean i i the comments by the way
we just released two minutes ago
actually the uh the footage on youtube
for anybody who wants to go see that
dillon bird cv but we talked to people
who told us that like biden hated
catholics that the vaccine was evil the
mark of the beast
uh we had people tell us actually there
was one man who was flying a chinese
flag saying it's already china might as
well just like please our new overlords
right
uh the there and of course there was a
person who admitted to uh
storming the capital and he said that
though he was a victim of police
brutality he was trying to like put that
angle on it and the reason why he said
he was made so much that it and this is
his worthy not mine that they maced my
balls it dripped down his whole body
they makes them so much that's uh sounds
more of a physics problem than anything
else i would i would agree there
the one thing i was gonna say is and
this is listen this is a suggestion
which is worth what you paid for it
which is nothing but one of the things i
thought might be and maybe you did this
later i only watched a little bit there
were times when you were interviewing
someone and they would say something
completely crazy
and you would counter point them with
like an opposing fact which is obviously
great but one of the things i stopped
doing
is
one of the reasons i stopped doing that
in those situations is
we can't possibly have the opposing
facts on all of these things even if we
know people are feeding us [ __ ] so i
tend to take the approach of when i know
someone saying something completely
bonkers
just keep asking them how they learned
that how they came up with that
rather than trying to counterpoint them
because eventually you might get to a
point where your counterpoint you don't
have the facts either because what
they're saying is so cop bonkers and so
you kind of get to a standstill where i
found that it often works out better
just to keep saying really where did you
hear that how did you learn that how do
you know that that's true and then they
end up hanging themselves in a way where
maybe they wouldn't if you just keep
going point counterpoint with them it's
just an idea you know and maybe you were
doing that later too i don't know it is
true i mean
i eventually ran into a guy who was
telling me how bill gates ran the u.n
and i would ask him where he heard that
and then he of course freaked out and
that did work better and i guess um uh
what was the old uh the old termite the
whole thing i was told it was something
along the lines of uh uh no one earns no
one wins anything from uh winning
against a fool right if you're debating
somebody who's a complete whack job you
you gain nothing if you look good right
job but if you actually trip up in any
way
then you just look like 10 times the
full because you lost to a complete
whack job that's another reason why i
think it's better in those situations
just to keep asking them questions about
how they learned this stuff because at
any point that you're not
as
even aware of what they're talking about
it almost ends up kind of looking like
well either of them might have been
right you know what i mean
yeah i there was one moment which i
especially liked where i asked somebody
they said that everything you're saying
is oxymoronic and i said define that
word and then they just like shut down
and just just getting them just asking
them for the definitions of what they're
saying their voices that probably that
un-ironically was the best
moments and on all the interviews that i
had
um so i i do agree with you on that
actually that's not surprising to me
that that happened
yeah i mean this is the third big thing
i went to the last two was the million
mag of march
and that's where i got maced by the
proud boys and that was that was a joy
the other one was january 6 which uh i
made the
uh the very intelligent decision to go
to the january 6th because at the time i
just thought it was going to be protest
yeah and a biden hoodie
i went there in a biden hoodie alone
which was a fool's errand i can say but
i i did not get physically assaulted so
i you know i got out better than i think
logic would say i would have gotten out
of that did authorities at all want to
talk to you just because you were there
i have never been contacted by
authorities and the thing that's
interesting about that is i got
a decent amount of pictures video
um i streamed a decent amount of it and
when i got i got up to the capital steps
and i even i actually got i think the
only angle that's available online of
them physically attacking the reporters
oh okay as everybody knows they they
attacked the reporters took their
equipment smashed it most people have
seen the footage afterwards where
they're smashing equipment right i
actually um saw the interaction that led
up to that what happened was it was
right after most of the chaos that
happened and they were pushed out of the
capital and so everybody is now kind of
outside the capital kind of combating
with police as police try to gain order
and then there's the reporters there and
they have this tiny little metal gate
dividing them from from the rioters and
one of the reporters just says there's a
riot behind me at the d.c capital
which is true under anyone's definition
even if you wanted to be as generous as
you wanted to the people who were
participating in that day
and one of the people there got so angry
that they used to term riot that they
came up with an american flag and
started waving in front of the camera so
they can record anything and then other
people gathered then they started
pelting them with objects before tearing
down the metal gear barrier pushing them
all out and smashing up their equipment
wow and so
basically
they rioted in response to being called
a riot
it became a self-fulfilling prophecy of
sorts
exactly it became a self-fulfilling
prophecy how many hours were you were
you there that day
i was there from i would say noon to
maybe about five or six oh okay did you
bring did you bring snacks
uh i did not bring snacks uh that was
also another error i made i
maybe you know in a tricky situation i
think that if i if i got cornered i
could open a bag of lay's potato chips
throw a couple in the air and maybe
they'd scatter yeah yeah yeah are you
bit what are you like a barbecue guy or
what potato chip flavor
you know i salt and vinegar has always
been the way i go ooh that that makes me
question this interview to be honest i
mean i i know it takes it takes a
dignifying modern man to like salt and
vinegar and i am the of the younger
variety right yeah yeah no barbecue is
barbecue's the way i now i'm curious in
all seriousness
were the riot did the rioters bring food
and drinks
i did not see any food and drinks there
but there were people with backpacks
they were i mean there were people with
these these like larpers and like full
military gear with everything geared up
backpacks and i'm sure if you opened it
up you wouldn't find military equipment
you'd mostly probably find like maybe
like juice boxes and snacks like some
oreos and stuff i'm sure obviously a few
of them had military equipment uh bombs
were planted at the uh at the capitol i
mean i've left the rnc and dnc the night
before and of course there was other
other weapons found as many people were
arrested with weapons did you since you
were in the crowd did you see people
with weapons
um
i saw people using traditional objects
with weapons as weapons like like a pole
yeah like stuff like that i never saw
anybody like take out like a knife or
like like a baseball bat it was like um
using for example the metal gate the
barrier like using that to push against
people i never saw any uh actual like
weapons get taken out there was a lot of
people
with um i would say like military gear
like fully geared up there was a lot of
people with like like full camo or
completely in black all things covered
and they have elbow pads and everything
like they're ready for something right
sure uh like mo brooks was ready because
he had body armor for some reason
that's weird to me
yeah that's the one thing i really want
answered is why how why did mo brooks
have body armor when no one else was
supposed to when he wasn't supposed to
know of what happened or what was going
to happen it's very very strange yeah
i've not
has they has there even been an
explanation asserted for that even if
it's bs
absolutely nothing did we just know he
had
um body armor which of course obviously
implies that he thought there was a high
likelihood of violence or knew there was
going to be violence right even the best
case scenario would be
that he knew there was a high likelihood
which raises a whole other series of
obvious questions which we've not gotten
answers to
of course of course so yeah january 6
was was wild
the the thing that got me about january
6 so there was some there's a few things
that were interesting how open people
were with their calls for like actual
like revolution and overthrow that i
think
i i think is really dug into me with
like being firsthand there like people
just calling for random politicians to
be executed right people just calling
for anybody who voted the other way to
be executed i remember there was one
interaction i had at the capitol steps
where
somebody i was i they saw my biden
hoodie and they got angry and they
started talking to me and they said i
was a traitor for just voting for biden
there was nothing else there it wasn't
like you're traitor because you're part
of biden's government or you did this
thing just merely voting the other way
made me a traitor and then later when i
was declared a trader people what of
course followed up with
what happens to traders what's the
penalty for treatment
which what's the the obvious implication
there is you should be shot or hung or
executed in some manner sure and the
other thing that was interesting was the
weird divide amongst the protesters on
how to interact with the police because
half of them were very much like we
respect you and stuff and you're great
you're the boys in blue and the other
half was just like [ __ ] them they're
traitors they're breaking they're oath
breakers what's the term i heard a
decent amount that like that they broke
in their oath and they're therefore
they're against the people and that i
guess was their justification for them
attacking a group they are usually very
supportive of what a wild day
like conflict with each other yeah it
was
um i had no clue i was in for that type
of a day and i wouldn't have gone alone
or in a biden hoodie if i knew that was
that's why i didn't go to this weekend
at a bite in hoodie because i'm right no
i think that was smart now you were
wearing a mask in a lot of the
interviews i saw
did anybody mention anything about that
because most of the people there were
not wearing masks yeah most of the
people there were not i would say maybe
like one in four to maybe one at three
if i'm being very generous with wearing
masks and most of those people were
counter protesters counter protesters a
lot of them just went in and out of the
protest at free which actually surprised
me the cops were very very ready they
had them basically surrounded i looked
up to the capitol steps and there were
cops all over it they were not taking
any chances which i would assume after
losing so many of their colleagues
there's a reason why they're not taking
any chances right um but when it comes
to masks i was they never brought up my
mask they did bring up are you do you
have the mark of the beast right have
you been vaccinated and i would always
say yes and then they'd like go on a
diatribe for five minutes about how i've
accepted satan or or bill gates's spawn
or i'm a u.n dog something along those
lines did anybody uh tell you to step
away because you were shedding vaccine
on them
once actually that did happen somebody
did uh tell me like
um like hey i don't need that i don't i
don't need the mask
you need to keep that mask to keep that
vaccine away from me right that's
something actually was cut out of the
final footage we uploaded to youtube but
you can still find that in the vault on
my twitch channel if somebody wanted to
see that there was this there was this
fellow that was very interesting he
looked like somebody just
came straight out of the coal mines in a
pickup truck right i don't know how else
to describe the man no mask no nothing
he had his whole depopulation sign he
was implying that the vaccines were
depopulation and and he was telling me
how bill gates owns the un and i said
how
and then
that was where that interaction
basically ended where he was like well
how i mean like he just does and like
well okay it was what about the vaccine
that's that's
bill gates too how and then of course it
would trip him up again so there was no
deeper explanation
there was no deeper experiment what he
would tell me is that wow you're a
reporter and you haven't done the
research as if he he asserts that bill
gates owns right right right supposed to
have a record of bill gates finances on
hand while i'm at a protest to do with
nothing associated with bill gates so
are you i mean the the i'm guessing
you're you weren't you're not dissuaded
from doing more of these in-person
things because it was basically fine
over the weekend
oh yeah i mean the the first two i went
to were obviously the most violent
emilia magamarch um
i actually had to try to get medical
help for somebody who was stabbed oh my
god we were charged uh which was
that was an experience wow
and the dc protests or january 6th
instruction whatever the hell you want
to call it that obviously um while i
never had physical violence done against
me that night which i still think is a
miracle
i saw enough of it and i saw enough type
of rhetoric thrown my way to
elite teach me a few lessons on how to
approach protests going forward like you
never go alone right a big tip i'd
always give everybody because what would
happen a lot of times with the proud
boys of the million maga march is they
would find people walking home alone and
if they wearing too much black you're
just gonna get jumped right on the
belief that they're antifa or what yes
oh i think that they're anti-fun
if you're wearing too much black then
you look like antifa you're going to get
jumped right and you don't know how much
help you're going to get from the cops
sometimes it's a lot sometimes it's none
it really depends on their resources it
depends on where they are and a lot of
times you'll just like watch the cops
will be there and nothing will happen
maybe it's because they don't feel they
have the means to do it or i have no
clue i'm not an expert in police tactics
right always go with like buddies
um would be like the number one tip i've
learned because the first two times i
didn't go with buddies and that was
and i'm very lucky that nothing happened
to me yeah that seems at minimum like
the minimum you want to do go go in a
group
um so what did you want to talk about
today i know i mean you're you know
you're uh
is it producer do you have a production
team is that who was contacting me uh
danabo is my assistant he was the one
who thought uh me talking to you was a
good idea yeah and so he was just like
let me just message him i was like sure
whatever i didn't think i didn't think
anything was obviously something dead
yeah yeah yeah he didn't say too much
about what you what did you want to talk
about i mean i'm glad to talk about
whatever if i just don't know i'll say i
don't know
okay i mean i was i was just willing to
talk about i think the the biggest
things i wanted to talk about well first
was those two events uh generally
because i know that like there's not a
lot of first-hand accounts and we just
had one over the weekend but another
thing i wanted to talk to you at length
about specifically wait one second i had
a list no come back to my list i have
terrible memory
uh oh actually was the afghanistan
withdrawal oh okay she's gotten a lot of
a lot of notice so first i just wanted
to ask you what is your general
i
idea around number one did you support
the withdrawal and number two how do you
think biden handled it i i support and
supported the withdrawal um i uh yeah i
i think you know we were there
too long
to put it lightly um i think that the
handling could have been better
but i also think that trump would have
screwed up the withdrawal um i think it
became clear you know when trump was
interviewed on newsmax when he was
actually asked well what would you have
done differently there wasn't really
anything that he presented that he would
have done differently
um and i uh you know i am really
disgusted with with this
corporate media
um concern i almost call it concern
trolling where they've scrutinized the
withdrawal after 20 years more than they
ever scrutinized being there
and um even like the drone strike
which you know this commander the
centcom commander recently said
um hey you know what we didn't get isis
k we got 10 civilians including maybe
like seven kids i think it was and we're
sorry
even the media seizing on that it's like
we were talking about that all the time
under obama but it just wasn't really
interesting to corporate media in the
same way
so even that feels like another way to
kind of say
we told you the withdrawal was a bad
idea look at this drone strike that went
wrong even though there's
hundreds thousands of instances
of uh
of similar of similar drone strikes that
did not garner that much attention so
yeah i'm i'm glad that we are out
to the extent that we're really out
right and there's a question as to
whether you know that the contractors go
back in or are we fully out um i think
that at a certain point
even though you break it you buy it
applies to some degree
at a certain point when it becomes clear
that just staying another year or two or
three or four
isn't actually going to fix anything
um you have to say
we are now getting out
what i found interesting about what
you're saying here is
not only did they give more attention to
withdrawal but there was many norms that
were broken under trump when it came to
afghanistan and just general foreign
policy
like like behavior that did not get
nearly as much coverage for example if
we're so concerned about drone strikes
which obviously the drone strike is
horrific the fact that civilians died
i've covered it on my channel it
deserves to be covered but where was
this attention to detail when
trump escalated drone strike use by
massive numbers in afghanistan yeah not
only did he do that but he followed it
up by restricting access to information
about said drone strikes
so he first he escalates drone strikes
drops the mother of all bombs on
afghanistan uh on afghanistan the moab
and then restricts access
to the data about what he's now doing in
afghanistan and across the middle east
right yeah i think that that's part of
why
the there's the political and there's
the media coverage
the media coverage seems so cynical so
cynical
it i i 100 believe it which is
frustrating for me as somebody who who
specializes in specifically foreign
policy because what i'm what i'm
watching happen in afghanistan right now
is absolutely horrific right women have
now basically been told they're not
going to be able to get secondary
education education like middle school
and high school but that what we would
think of that in afghani and america is
not going to be available to women and
girls boys have gone back to school
women have not that's the same thing
they did with work in the 90s that they
just said hey don't go to work right now
and it wasn't until america invaded that
that policy of course was reversed uh we
have seen the tick tock comedians get
executed we have seen all these horrific
things happen and i and i'm covering
them and it's important to cover these
things but what what sucks
is i feel
like number one these things are now
getting more attention because we're not
there and it's easy to basically like
like say we'll see this is all the fault
of the withdrawal and number two
it's aggravating because i feel like i'm
sitting there and i'm talking about all
these human rights abuses and everybody
and these people walk into the room and
they're like oh yeah i agree with you
and then i'll move on to say saudi
arabia or i'll move on to say um well
let's talk about women's rights in the
united states let's talk about texas and
then the room just everybody exits like
never mind okay i'm gone yeah we don't
want to hold those standards universally
the other thing this reminds me of
that's also just kind of an absurdity of
the way that these things are talked
about is
um i don't know any i i don't want to
like gatekeep with the term real
progressive or real leftist but i think
the point i'm trying to make is
i don't know
any serious critics of our involvement
in afghanistan
who think the taliban is is great
or
trustworthy or whatever and there's been
this um sort of like black white
reaction where if you say you like the
withdrawal in that you think it's the
right thing
all of a sudden there's oh you want to
be negotiating with the taliban and
you're the these are the people and then
they pull out the pictures like no the
taliban's horrible and the taliban was
horrible when trump was negotiating with
them and the taliban's been horrible for
a long time but that's a different
question then what are we staying for
what will be achieved by staying and is
it is it the right decision they're
really they're related questions but
they're they're separate issues
yeah i i find it hard to believe
that also the standard is held
universally because there's been many
times in american history that these
same individuals who are crying foul
right now have negotiated with powers as
bad or or pretty bad and in comparison
with the taliban or just generally for
example
stalin was an absolute monster he was
one of the worst human beings to ever
exist on the planet but we negotiated
with him in world war ii because we saw
a bigger enemy right sure we have
negotiated with saudi arabia which has a
terrible human rights record we've
negotiated with right-wing death strat
uh death squads in latin america for our
own benefit
even though we 100 shouldn't have even
been there in the first place right and
so it's weird for me to see this this
crying foul on the idea of of any
compromise whatsoever after they failed
on a certain strategy for 20 years now
let's say that
it was year one or two maybe you could
have an argument like okay it's the
first two years against the fight
against the taliban maybe you're right
maybe we should just but it's been 20
years 20 years of failed strategy now
you can maybe unless you want to tell me
okay let's go another 20 years then you
have to at least give credence to the
idea of looking at other strategies and
how to deal with it yeah yeah well
that's the question right which is for
those that are now saying well we should
have stayed
the question is
how long would be reasonable because if
20 years didn't accomplish whatever
one year more is unlikely to do it so
then you're already talking about well
by saying stay are you saying stay five
more years are you saying another 20.
and you know there were a couple i don't
remember who they were they were but
there were a couple of neocon neocons i
saw in right-wing media who were
actually honest and they were like yeah
we should just have a permanent presence
there and it's like while i disagree
well i disagree completely at least
they're just being upfront and they're
like i think leaving's bad because we
should just stay forever that's it and
it's like okay all right i can deal with
you if you're honest in that sense
that's only the first part of the puzzle
too because then the question isn't just
how long are we staying but also what
are we going to change in strategy right
because
i would not dedicate a soldier to stay
another day in a country if our
strategy's failing and we don't have
another strategy to fix it because at
that point what you're doing is you're
just clogging holes in a sinking ship
and you're just going with the same old
strategy that hasn't worked for the last
20 years we have no reason to believe
that it's going to work in the next 20.
i would also say on the other hand that
i do want to bring attention to this
that it also has been difficult as
somebody who
covers these human rights abuses that's
going on in afghanistan and covered them
while the withdrawal was happening and
talking about what the reality was going
to be with the taliban ruling
afghanistan to any time i'd bring that
up it felt like somebody would say
i would bring up the taliban or awful
evil and bad and we need to talk about
what the reality is going to be for
women in afghanistan and some would say
it sounds like just pro-war machine
propaganda where i think that
left-wingers generally need to
acknowledge the consequences of foreign
policy decisions that we cannot pretend
that if when we exit a country or when
we leave this environment that
everything is going to be peaches and
cream and everything is going to be
wonderful we need to acknowledge the
pain that's going to be caused to women
and minority group like the hazard
population of afghanistan
and talk about what we should do moving
forward to best help them my strategy is
to take in as many refugees as
physically possible and then see where
we can go from there right
uh but it felt like also anytime i bring
up any of that there would also be a
weird a weird um virtue signally
backlash in the other direction i hate
to play the both sides on that but it it
felt weird no there was it was going on
now what do you imagine that because
remember trump trump announced the same
plan to leave afghanistan trump
announced it imagine trump had done it
and the same chaos had taken place
what would the trump pr machine have
done would they simply have said hey you
got to blame george w bush he's the guy
who got us in and just left it at that
and not explained anything else and just
made it that cut and dry
i think the first thing i do want to say
about trump that's interesting about
afghanistan is he starred in his
administration
with a troop increase in afghanistan
increasing drone strikes restricting
data to that information and helping the
moab and then by the end of his
administration which he was saying
on the campaign trail bombed the
families with terrorists he's like well
let me negotiate with some of them yeah
yeah just to complete 180 and it shows
that and i mean this that a lot of
people like to like to say that trump's
like just like like an isolationist or
he has this foreign policy he doesn't
have any fundamental foreign policy
beliefs right
he just sticks his finger in the air and
goes that way he was for the war in iraq
he was four intervening in libya he was
he was four going into afghanistan he
was for all these conflicts and now that
is politically beneficial he's going the
other way he just sticks his finger in
the air so i just i just want to like
say that he has the fundamental form of
course
so i i honestly think that he probably
would have stayed maybe with the may
deadline that he set i have no reason to
believe and he hasn't indicated that he
would have switched that deadline
and i think that
he would have handled the situation
either as bad or worse
because i don't know if he could have
been able to have the logistical skills
or be able to point the right people in
the right direction
you have one of the largest airlifts in
human history because i will say the
biden administration most certainly
dropped the ball in a few things i'm
sure the leaving of biometric data um
his oh my god the interview after the um
the person fell off the plane to their
death and he's like oh that's four or
five days i mean that's just terribly
callous right
absolutely
i think maybe a higher level of
callousness might have been shown by a
different individual
and i don't know if he would have been
able to do that airlift or pick i've
been able to re-pick up the ball right
right so that's that's the way i like to
classify uh bidens with y'all is he's
dropped the ball then he picked it up
and did what he could do in the fastest
way possible
a trump withdrawal would have been
months earlier in may
he would not have had the logistical
skill or the management skills to get
this done
and he would have been 10 times more
callous and all those allies that we're
talking about
we needed to support and bring out
needed to be included in the airlift
they would have been considered less
because he plays to a base of people who
don't like to take in refugees he said
on the campaign trail i want a total and
complete shutdown of muslims entering in
the united states yeah now it might
surprise people to hear this but uh
afghanistan actually has a lot of those
uh
within the borders of afghanistan and so
and you see the right-wing fear-monger
regime right now brian is bringing in a
horde of refugees i russia today
actually edited
ak-47s and rpgs onto the backs i saw
that with their children going on and
wasn't there explanation that it was
satire but like there was nothing that
would indicate that it was satire it was
one of the strangest explanations it was
just not it just looked like a story
headline it was weird um russia today
has a long history of pushing like just
their main goal is to push divisive
divisive messaging to the highest extent
for divisiveness sake and for clicks
another example of this is i remember
when hillary clinton uh they they had
this story that i think has been removed
from the youtube since then if this
person talking about how basically the
jews are controlling a large part of
hillary clinton's campaign and then hey
look there's a triangle in one of the
symbols of their company and it was just
posted yeah oh yeah it was posted on the
youtube eventually was taken down but
they have a long history of pushing and
uh blatantly uh bigoted messaging yeah
so let's see i i generally speaking
agree with you about how trump would
have handled the withdrawal i think the
reaction uh would have been callous is
probably an understatement but i
certainly agree with you about that i do
think that you know trump was able
to come up with these
it's not just they weren't just
incoherent but they were almost like
satirical
public positions when he would screw
stuff up
um
and i'm kind of i'm almost i have like a
morbid curiosity what kind of insane
thing with jared kushner have dreamed up
to explain
the exact same level of chaos or even
more if trump
did actually oversee the withdrawal from
from afghanistan it's cert i don't
actually know what it would be
but you know particularly on covid and
on hurricanes like on everything he was
just able to do stuff who could imagine
i am scared that he would have done the
withdrawal then reversed his decision oh
interesting why is because if we see
syria now that was a withdrawal that was
horribly botched and didn't even need to
happen because when you look at the
withdrawal he pulled the troops out of
northeastern syria off the border after
making the kurds the ypj and the ypg
disarm themselves on the border with the
deal with turkey
then he moves them back they get
slaughtered politicians get dragged out
of cars and shot i don't i don't need to
describe the brutal but it was terrible
he redeploys the money rock says they're
coming home and then just redeploys them
back into syria right just completely
reverses the decision the only
difference was now they were in a worse
strategic position and now thousands
more people were dead that was the only
difference and so my fear is and that
was due to the backlash of people
walking into his office and pointing at
charts and saying but there's oil in
syria trump that was i think that was
mitch mcconnell who did that so that my
fear is that he would have been going
through with this withdrawal made the
deal with the taliban
gone with this made deadline been as
catastrophical more catastrophic than
midway through after chaos was happening
since he has no fundamental foreign
policy beliefs and joe biden for years
has talked about in private how he
wanted to get out of afghanistan he
there's there's a lot of these things
coming out in 20 from um i think it was
2011 where he had a conversation with a
staffer with someone who was trying to
convince him like maybe we should stay
for the feminism he's like not a dude
that's nonsense that's nonsensical right
i'm curious though
if if the wind
pushed him in that direction he could he
could have reversed his position on
afghanistan like that yeah yeah i don't
i don't disagree um i think though that
there is
you know trump will sometimes off-ramp
things that he promises
but he'll never really just say i
changed my mind because because the
situation changed you know he'll say
well someone blocked me from doing it or
it's rhinos or it's democrats or
whatever so while i agree with you that
on policy he could have ended up saying
we're not doing it or we're going back
in but he never would have said because
it got chaotic and i didn't predict that
he would always have figured out some
way to either blame other republicans
who got in the way or democrats or
whoever because that's always that's
it's just there's no instances where he
said i miscalculated you would have put
it probably on the afghans that the the
a a just collapsed so fast because the
afghan people are just so cowardly and
so terrible i think
hey that's a a foreign enemy he can pin
it on right that's the type of thing as
a type of dialogue i can see i'm doing
because you can see that dialogue going
on right now because there's so many
reports of a a soldiers being
tremendously brave but if you don't have
supplies you don't have ammunition and
you're also starving there's many
reports of them just not getting fed
even and not paid on top of that right
and you're facing the taliban like yeah
no [ __ ] many of them weren't able to
hold out right but he could just pin it
on the cowardly uh foreigners not being
able to hold up defense even though
we've saved them for 20 years i could
see him running running along with that
i mean that's what they're doing right
now i mean they're saying why do all
these afghans need to come to america
why aren't they at home fighting the
taliban fighting for their own country
if they love these values so much
i'm curious because you you know you
mentioned the rt edited uh image you
know with the the afghans
and the weapons the rocket launcher i
think it was or whatever the case it was
there's a there's a contingent i mean rt
is controversial on the left not for me
like i i am i'm an anti-authoritarian
period so any kind of authoritarian
leaders and their associated state media
entities i'm very skeptical about
garbage i don't uh i don't use rt as a
source i don't use telesur as a source i
don't use al jazeera you know we it
doesn't doesn't matter we could go on
and do the full list but what do you
think it is about
that fundamentally underlies this
disagreement on the left about a network
like rt
i i think that the problem is that
press tv russia today or al jazeera or
any of these um and al jazeera
unironically i will watch some of their
documentaries or i for example i love
mehdi hassan i think maddie hassan is an
amazing journalist and he was with al
jazeera for years he was yeah he would
do this amazing head-to-head series
which is phenomenal that was great
everybody go check it out and i would
see that and that reporting and his work
was phenomenal on the network right
and so
when you see good sources or good people
within a larger network doing good stuff
that's gonna rub you in in a good way
it's gonna make you think you know maybe
this is something worthwhile to listen
to and then you you and then you
condense that with the fact that russia
today and press tv a lot of times have
anti um like american imperialist
messaging why because russia serves it
russia today serves a different imperial
overlord right so it's not out of
anti-imperialist interest it's out of
anti-americanism it's the same thing
with gray's own it's not out of actual
anti-imperial interests it's out of
just anti-americanism
i'm not familiar with that one
uh you never you're not familiar with
gray zone no
you've never interacted with grayson
before ever who does that
uh jimmy dore uses them as a source all
the time i've i never watched jimmy dore
i've i've i've heard the name aaron mate
but i don't know
oh max i've met a couple mats max i've
met a couple of times
yeah well well
these different types of sources i think
they a lot of times can unironically hit
the nail on the head where they'll if
something bad happens america does
something bad they'll criticize it
they'll point it out and they're correct
but then the problem is the reason
they're pointing it out is different
than the reason that somebody else is
pointed out their their interests and
their motives are different and then
with that they'll splice it in with man
isn't it terrible that they're doing all
this and let me tell you how great the
russian government was in supporting
assad and then those lace in their own
personal injuries yeah that's why we
need to be concerned because you're not
going to see russia today calling out
bashar al-assad's use of barrel bombs
you're not going to see press tv
talking about the treatment of women in
iran you're not going to see that
reporting done because it doesn't
interest those who fund the programs
yeah you know the thing um that i've
talked about i mean this is starting to
sort of get into
really the debate even among the left
about quote russia gate as some people
like to call it
where
you know as i've said before
you have this spectrum where on one side
you might have like putin and trump in a
room planning something right which i
mean maybe someone was saying that i was
never saying that you go back to april
2017 and i'm saying guys if that's what
you're waiting for you're going to be
sorely disappointed on the other side is
just kind of like the systemic critique
that you're putting together which is
hey you know what particularly when you
think geopolitically about china russia
and the united states as like the three
superpowers um there is a
to some degree a zero-sum nature of that
and the authoritarian uh um uh regime of
vladimir putin comparatively looks
better
if democracy looks like it's in peril in
the united states if things look really
chaotic in the united states so it's
like of course they would prefer the
doofus trump to hillary
that's very different than putin and
trump got together and planned something
if that if that if i'm being clear
yeah the thing that gets me
is every time i hear somebody well you
probably believe in russiagate which is
something you'll commonly see in like
twitter section one yeah yeah yeah is
it's not really an issue of debate
anymore what what what happened there's
certain details that are foggy right yep
but when it comes to the internet
research agency when it comes to the
multiple reports put out by our
intelligence agency clarifying very
clearly that they did spread
disinformation on the internet to
benefit one political candidate because
they thought the other would act against
their interests that is absolutely clear
now you can downplay that if you want
but it is true that they attempted to
interfere in both the 2016 elections and
to a lesser extent the 2020 election
that is just a fact now you can say oh
so you're just saying they just posted a
lot of memes la mao
they tried to spread this information
online to try to tip the scale on one
way i'm pretty sure in other any other
circumstance if it didn't if it didn't
benefit your political uh if it if it
went the other way let's say that it was
the chinese government
spread this information online in the
united states to help joe biden sure
and then a report came out showing that
right and it was saying hunter biden
best intellectual of this century
big brained uh amazing man big chad
money muscle
and we saw those types of stuffs being
spread on the internet by the chinese
government and their internet research
agency do you really think we would get
the same down plane or would it be
chinese propaganda destroys american
election it would be a totally it would
be a hundred percent the same type of
coverage that we got on the rachel
maddow show of this and if this issue
yeah and then there's one other thing as
well which is sometimes there will be
sort of like rebuttals that aren't
really substantive rebuttals which like
i'll give you a couple of examples one
would be
um
yeah but russia's doing that in a lot of
countries
i would agree with you that's not
actually a rebuttal i've done an inter
i've done interviews about that and and
that actually would be sort of like an
aggravator that would make us think well
then why wouldn't they try it in the
united states and then the other one
that will sometimes be put together is
well but the us has a history of doing
the same thing it's like of course look
at latin america as you mentioned before
i we can be against that too that
doesn't change the reality of what took
place they're not really rebuttals
they aren't rebuttals and i the thing
the thing that gets me about the later
example is so what you're saying is that
you're acknowledging that when america
did that it was bad right right so
then you would acknowledge that this is
bad as well then obviously unless what
you mean is we deserve it and therefore
they're right i'm like why would how is
that even relevant otherwise well then
that it just becomes like like somebody
like taking a belt and like hurting
themselves at that point that's like
almost advocating for the like the type
of weird self-harm of the united states
so yeah i i feel that people just want
to downplay what happened or they want
to just kind of
petty fog the issue
but
ultimately the fact of the matter is
that the russian government attempted
through the internet research agency to
affect the outcomes of both the 2016 and
to a lesser extent of 2020 elections
through spreading disinformation on the
internet that is an undeniable fact and
i think any time somebody brings up
russiagator mocks it just put it in that
framing and just don't move from the
point they can try to say oh they posted
a few memes and
and then you can say actually we can
just look at the report and see exactly
what they did because the dis you can
say it's a few memes it wasn't a few
memes their disinformation were seen by
millions upon millions upon millions of
people
and when you're talking about election
where one candidate hillary clinton won
the popular vote and the other didn't
win the popular vote and some of the
races in some of these states were a lot
closer than i think some people in both
camps would have liked
they can have an actual impact yeah i
mean i think um not even to talk about
the actual efforts of the russian
government to hack into that's a totally
separate issue that's separate i think
either way if you come up against the
determined denier they'll they'll kind
of use the same lines which is well
your sourcing on that is from
untrustworthy
uh organizations or too much of the data
is still classified so we don't really
know i mean like you know they'll
they'll you can still get stonewalled on
that stuff
yeah i i think what it is is that it's
an inconvenient fact
that people want to pretend
that for what i don't know why it could
be any number of reasons
uh it could be either you're a trump
supporter and maybe it makes you feel
that the election would feel less
legitimate if trump won
uh with the backing of a foreign
government i mean that's the type of
thing that they would like to accuse the
democrats of dewey not the republicans i
mean that's exactly what happened in
2020 hunter biden china is in china's
pocket that's exactly what happened four
years after 2016.
um and maybe there's some people who
don't want don't like the idea that the
russian government tried to interfere or
uh an american maybe part of it is like
an american exceptionalist like nah
there's no way the foreigners could
could have an impact on american
elections maybe some people have an
interest in
just believing that russia had no
involvement because russia said they
didn't have involved well there's one
other there's one other uh section which
is i i don't know if they still would
would cop to this but early
there were bernie people
who
wanted to believe that
so the logic would be bernie was the
better candidate than hillary
bernie would have beaten hillary so we
need to believe that trump really beat
hillary fair and square
if russia did try or succeed at helping
trump
then maybe hillary would have won which
undercuts our view that bernie was the
better candidate and actually would have
won so i think that's another contingent
i i think that could possibly be i
haven't seen as much of that i think
i've seen it maybe on a few occasions
yeah
but i
there is and
there's a thing that really angers me
about this is
there are
there are people who try to say and
point to the fact that hillary clinton
acknowledges that this happened
right and she talks about this to point
to the fact see hillary clinton didn't
accept the results of the 2016 election
why does donald trump need to accept the
results of the 2020 election even though
hillary of course
called uh mr trump
literally the day after yeah and said
hey
you're president i give up i'm tapping
out right and all the legal challenges
that they try to bring up she dropped
them all of them did she didn't pursue
any of those not to mention trump still
doesn't accept the results of the 2016
election
the the thing that gets me about trump
is he has been telling people he was
going to do this for the last five years
right he said during on the republican
campaign trail when he lost any a
primary he would say was due to fraud or
was stolen or was rigged or there was
some factor like
evil ben carson or ted cruz or whatever
right that's also and this is a fun fact
that's also where donald trump laid the
foundations for the growth in the
anti-vaxxer movement when he said that
vaccines cause autism on the same stage
as a medical expert and uh ben carson
did not sufficiently call him out and i
think that laid the foundation for a lot
of what we're seeing no doubt then after
being elected
um and then of course on the on the
debate stage he said he didn't answer if
he would accept the results of the
election then come 2019 to the lead-up
of the next election he said if he loses
it's rigged he he has been very open
that if he ever loses just outright
loses he's not going to accept the
results
and so i don't understand how people can
see him priming this up then he pulls
the trigger
on this and people are like
wow i'm so shocked i can't believe the
democrats stole it and they're
legitimately believing this lie he's
been setting this lie up for five years
yeah and they're applying it i mean look
you know if you watched what happened
with larry elder last week they're now
just using it in other elections there's
a video of a woman confronting mitt
romney in uh washington at reagan
airport where she goes up to him and
says you didn't really win your utah
senate race that was that was also fraud
it's just gonna be it's the new thing
you know and here's the concern i have
and i wonder if you share this concern
and maybe not maybe the concern is
overblown
that it'll become like a reverse boy who
cried wolf
which is at some point
republicans really might find a way to
fraudulently steal an election and
democrats might actually call it out and
then republicans will say guys we've
been calling this out for so long and
you always said we were lying we can't
listen to you now did you see the six
points that were released uh about how
vite uh how about how mike pence was
supposed to steal the election so i i
bookmarked some articles and i'm gonna
cover it tomorrow but my understanding
is the gist of it was the alternate
slate of electors was like a big part of
the plan
yeah
it seemed that basically he was gonna
have mike pence fly down to arizona say
it's all fraud so all of these don't
count trump is president and then and
then in it he even says now the
democrats the boohoo democrats might not
accept that and so then we go to the
house it's a fraud which is still
technically republican-controlled at the
time it was
and then boom baby we got this election
don't don't even sweat it they're gonna
sue us we'll just fight them in court
right right absolutely and um
basically what they were
basically just saying with this if if
this was completely let's say this was
all legally true this would imply
that all you needed to do to steal a
presidential election is just have the
house of representatives right exactly
yeah and you know a willing participant
i guess and a vice president in order to
publicize that this is what's going on
and this this is what's being done which
you know now there's people saying like
thank goodness it was pence and not matt
gates as the vp or something like that i
i don't know i mean i'm still thinking
about how much of a difference that
really would have made in the end i
don't know if the thing is i feel that
there is no legal basis for what they
were going to do no so therefore even if
you put the biggest trump sycophant in
there unless it's somebody who actually
believes trump's nonsense which i don't
know if matt gates
uh uh or as they call him pedogates
really believes uh the nonsense or if
he's just a political opportunity if
he's a political opportunist then he's
not gonna be able to do anything and
he'll just probably just stand there or
maybe he said i tried to and the evil
democrats stopped me or something like
that yeah no question
i doubt a real attempt would would
legitimately be made i agree i tend to
agree
um
dil so i don't i don't know if you if
word got to you i have like about an
hour which started you know like 50
minutes ago so were there other things
you wanted to talk to me about i know
your your audience is mentioning a lot
of different things and i'm glad to talk
about anything i don't want to feel like
we short change anything well it's i i
didn't know it was gonna i i i was told
it was gonna be a conversation at an
interview so if you have any questions
for me that's fine either but i can go
to chat and uh for the last question uh
sure uh we can do chat participation
chat what do you want me to ask david oh
my god this is exciting let me ask you a
question david me he's a very important
question oh sure yeah
uh what's your favorite ice cream
oof uh you know lately i'm into
greyton's black cherry chocolate chip
it's pretty strong
you really like to fill the liberal
elitist
is that an elite flavor
it feels like it just i listened to that
and it just felt like like i heard like
a clinging of a silver spoon hit the
floor so it fell out of your mouth when
you said that it's 4.99 for a pint i
mean is that pricey i don't know i don't
know it was just it was just the name
right it just sounded very fancy oh my
god i mean i'm generally speaking a
pistachio guy like whenever i i am
trying a new ice cream place
usually i kind of judge them by
pistachio
so this is this is the thing i'll just
ask you and you can ramble about it i
won't i won't ask you any more about it
but this is something that people have
people uh
have been telling me to ask you about
this before
um because it was something a while ago
and i covered this
a lot of people uh or were very upset
about your coverage on bolivia
were they i didn't know that
yeah there was maybe one or two people
who were upset about that so so i had a
question what do you think about the the
outrage do you think they had any fair
critique do you think it was just an
outrage mob what do you think about that
so on a bunch of these issues like um
venezuela
bolivia
um
what other examples are even argentina
i'm from argentina i don't know if you
knew that but just as a sort of
mentioned you know to mention i'm i was
born in argentina um and and came to the
u.s
i am
very uh
critical
of what i consider faux populist faux
left populists
i've been around the block too long on
latin american politics
to
be kind of entranced by
these figures that many american
leftists sort of fall in love with as
the poverty solvers and the democracy
bringers and this type of thing
and unfortunately you know how before i
was saying
on afghanistan
there it's almost like you can't both be
for the withdrawal
but not a taliban lover like people say
well if you're for the withdrawal you
must love the taliban or otherwise you
would say we have to stay in
similarly
there's a lot of the same thing
happening with me on latin america where
because i pointed out
some of the limitations of um uh
you know the chavez maduro regime and
its authoritarian nature people started
accusing me of supporting american
cia selection of guido and i made it
very clear i don't want the u.s involved
i'm from latin america and i understand
the long disastrous history of american
involvement and
all i'm saying is i'm an
anti-authoritarian
and
chavez maduro they control the media
they control the courts so i i have to
be against that as an anti-authoritarian
progressive but i don't want the us
involved and i'm not in favor of guido
similar in bolivia
i made very clear
even in the first segment which was the
source of a lot of the criticism hey
guys
the what was the woman's name uh jean uh
anya i don't even remember you know
yeah
i said this seems to be a right-wing nut
and it's quite plausible that
yeah that she's gonna take over and but
that doesn't mean and i don't want the
u.s involved but that doesn't mean that
i have to love everything that's been
going on in bolivia so basically you
know the
my basic view of this now would be
um
i know that people whenever i appear on
any show love to talk about this like
it's number one you know the the
foremost thing on my mind i don't think
i've even mentioned it for two years at
this point it doesn't really bother me
it's fine for people to
have to either say i'm either good or
bad on that issue
i think it's overly simplistic
but it's not surprising
given that kind of black white knee-jerk
tendency that that i see among many on
left and right
okay uh
so i just one clarifying question what
do you think of evil morales
i think that he is a slightly
less
how do i want to say it
i think he is
more genuine
in his
package of id of ideas
than someone like chavez or maduro
so i don't see him as the same type of
authoritarian as as like chavez maduro
um but
i think that
he fell
quite short of what i would see as a
kind of ideal of social democracy rather
than this kind of populist rhetoric that
in latin america often falls so woefully
short i think that's the way i would
kind of summarize it okay one last
question
is it a hot dog a sandwich
um it's a hot dog a sandwich i don't
know i mean i ask people that question
very often and i don't really know the
answer i i would say it is not
you don't think it would be in the
category of like sub sandwich then
i think it would be and i mean it's sort
of like a corn dog and a corn dog isn't
really a sandwich
you're just wrapping meat in carbs
well now i believe you are a fascist
i don't know listen i stopped eating
pork a long time ago so i'm kind of out
of that of the of the hot dog game
although i will occasionally have an all
beef kosher dog you know
okay so uh that's all the questions i i
have or um don't want to take any more
of your time i just do want to say one
thing though is i'm actually i'm
actually 20 um and i've been uh involved
in like local electoral politics and
like all this stuff since i was like 16
17. and i gotta say that when i was like
getting into politics you were one of
the shows that helped me actually get
into politics no way and i yeah and so i
just wanted to um thank you for that man
i appreciate that it's great to have
more p you're almost as old as the david
pakman show
well then it would make sense right i
guess you were four when the show
started i was six and you were four when
the show started so that that all adds
up before i was uh playing like uh i
don't know what i was playing the
nintendo wii maybe i don't know when was
the wii release though that was 2006. i
could my parents didn't allow me to have
video games so i don't know
really yeah why was that
they just thought it was bad i don't
know
i mean i had video games i had computer
games i want to make it clear i had
computer games all along but no consoles
i think they didn't like the idea of not
only the computer but also the tv being
taken over by video games i think that
was really it
that was really have you played video
games since then have you tried them of
course of course of course awesome you
like any video games
i'm i'm sort of just like i play the
grand theft auto games that was that's
like a series i've been into since i was
a lot younger um you know like uh when
former producer lewis told me to get
portal i i bought portal and played
portal but i i don't really know much
about the whole culture you know if
someone has me play something i'll play
it but i don't really know you know
people talk about valorant i don't know
i have no clue what that is i couldn't
tell you what that is don't don't don't
just don't do it don't get sucked into
that league of legends don't touch
either of those okay is valerian a first
person shooter it is a first person
shooter oh it is okay shooter it's a
team based shooter gotcha okay and it's
it's only is it single player or it's
only played multiplayer oh it's only
made played multiplayer okay got it got
it i'm more of a single player i like
stories like i like i like a video game
that's like a movie almost i love red
dead redemption 2 for example you know
there was a game that when we got our
first computer
which was like 100 megahertz pentium
which at the time you had the 100
megahertz and the 75 and it was like
we're going with 100 it's going to be so
blazing fast a game called pitfall came
with the computer
and i remember being into that game a
long time ago
well david i'm i'm happy uh oh i'm
getting a little blurry now so i guess
that's a single from my computer that i
need to skedaddle thank you so much for
having me on um can i just shout out my
stuff quick please yeah okay uh i might
be extremely blurry now but uh you know
what you can't find me blurry on my
youtube channel dylan burns tv we're
pushing it really hard right now we're
trying to get it to 50k we just released
a video of all my footage uh all the
interesting footage from my time at the
capitol uh please go check it out at
dylan burns tv that's dylan that's dylan
burns tv and thanks david i really
appreciate you having me on yeah my
pleasure and uh you know if anybody in
your audience wants to find me we're
trying to get to 100 000 on twitch so
just please follow me on twitch
and uh as far as i know that's still
legal as tucker carlson likes to say
um for now for now yeah
you're not lauren southern you haven't
been banned yet i have not yet been
banned yeah exactly you have been banned
awesome see you later man all right
thanks keep up the great work
you too man okay see ya
all right there is dylan burns um
[Music]
wow
wow
uh
we'll post that to the youtube channel i
think that was a great uh a great
conversation all right guys
thank you for joining me
trump rally saturday
i will see you
then you